الانتقادات الموجهه لرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان والمتمثله ببعده عن راي العام
يحاول غريبه الاول استغلالها لمصلحته
فيديوهات دعائيه عده انتشرت بكثره على
مواقع التواصل لكمال كل الشرق اوغلو مرشح
تحالف الامه المعارض لانتخابات الرئاسه
التركيه مرتديا قميصا ابيض اللون وفي
الخلفيه مطبخ منزلها المتواضع او مكتبته
هو يخاطب اوغلو الناخبين من خلال هذه
الصور محاولا اظهار انه يعيش حياه طبيعيه
وانه ليس سياسيا نخبويا بل يستطيع فهم
المشاكل من الناس مقاطع الفيديو هذا سعت
الى تقديم خصم اردوغان كشخصيه لطيفه شخصيه
مقبوله وكجسر لجيل سياسي جديد يختلف في كل
شيء عن اردوغان الذي غالبا ما يكون قتاليا
مستقدما رغم مواقفها المتقاربه بالسياسه
الخارجيه فيما يخص ملف اللاجئين كل شجار
استخدم كذلك مهاره الاستاذ في شرح خطته
الاقتصاديه في محاوله اخرى لمقارنه مؤهلات
مؤهلات اردوغان الذي يلقي باللوم على
ارائه الاقتصاديه غير التقليديه في مضاعفه
حجم التضخم وفق ما تقول واشنطن بوست كما
حقق احد الفيديوهات اكثر من 36 مليون
مشاهده ابدى فيه تطلعه للمساواه بين
المواطنين على اساس المواطنه الفيديو وصفه
البعض بمغازله جماعات توصف في الاقليات في
تركيا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات